all right it looks like we're now we're
now live for our second uh storytelling
with Sandler I have this uh very nice
volume here of Jorge Louis Borges uh
collected fictions so it's got the story
that we're going to go through today
which
um I'm hoping that's the people that are
here listening and watching have you
know encountered before if you haven't
you are in line for a real treat so it
is the lottery in Babylon which
um it's in a fairly early story it's one
that I encountered when I was in college
and one that helped me to fall in love
with Borge's writings so I'm not going
to go into too much background stuff
about it before I jump in
um
so I see somebody saying audio cutting
out nothing I can do about that uh and
that probably is you because uh it's up
to the internet and it's whims to do
things so in any case let me start and
um this is the lottery in Babylon a very
short short story but one with a lot of
interesting
philosophical suggestions built into it
so
like all the men of Babylon I have been
pro-consul like all I have been a slave
I have known omnipotence ignominy
imprisonment look here my right hand has
no index finger look here through this
gas this gash in my Cape you can see on
my stomach a crimson tattoo it is the
second letter Beth
on nights when the moon is full this
symbol gives me power over men with a
mark of gimmel but it subjects me to
those with The a-lift Who on nights when
there is no moon o obedience to those
marked with the gimmel in the half light
of dawn in a Cellar standing before a
black altar I have slit the throats of
sacred Bulls once for an entire lunar
year I was declared invisible
I would cry out no one would hear my
call I would steal bread and not be
beheaded I have known that thing the
Greeks knew not uncertainty
in a chamber of brass as I face the
Strangler silent scarf hope did not
abandon me in the river of delights
Panic has not failed me here at Clydes
ponticus reports admiringly that
Pythagoras recalled having been pyrus
and before that euphorobus and before
that some other Mortal in order to
recall similar vicissitudes I have no
need of death nor even of imposture
I owe that almost monstrous variety to
an institution the lottery which is
unknown in other nations or at work in
them imperfectly or secretly
I have not delved into this
institution's history I know that sages
cannot agree about its Mighty purposes I
know as much as a man untutored in
astrology might know about the moon
mine is a dizzying country in which the
lottery is a major element of reality
until this day I have thought as little
about it as about the conduct of the
indecipherable gods or of my heart now
far from Babylon and its beloved Customs
I think with some bewilderment about the
lottery and about the Blasphemous
conjectures that shrouded men whisper in
the half-light of dawn or evening
my father would tell how how once long
ago centuries years the lottery in
Babylon was a game played by commoners
he would tell the whether this is true
or not I cannot say
how Barbers would take a man's copper
coins and give back rectangles made of
bra bone or parchment and adorned with
symbols then in broad daylight a drawing
would be held those smiled upon by Fate
wood with no further corroboration by
chance win coins minted of silver the
procedure for a failure
no moral Force whatsoever they appealed
not at all to a man's faculties only to
his hopefulness public and soon virgin
who had founded these Vino lotteries
began to lose money
someone tried something new
including among the list of lucky
numbers
a few unlucky draws this Innovation
meant that those who bought those
numbered rectangles now had a two-fold
chance they might win a sum of money or
they might be required to pay fine
sometimes a considerable one
as one might expect at small risk for
every 30 good numbers there was one ill
almond one
peaked The public's interest Babylonians
flocked to buy tickets the man who
bought none was considered a
pusillanimous wretch a man with no
Spirit of Adventure
in time this Justified contempt found a
second target not just the man who
didn't play but also the man who lost
and paid the fine
the company as it was now beginning to
be known had to protect the interest of
the winners who could not be paid their
prizes unless the pot contained almost
the entire amount of the fines a lawsuit
was filed against the losers the judge
sentenced them to pay the original fine
plus court costs or spent a number of
days in jail
in order to thwart the company they all
chose jail
from that Gauntlet thrown down by a few
men spraying the company's omnipotence
it's ecclesiastical metaphysical Force
sometime after this the announcements of
the numbers drawn began to leave out the
lists of fines and simply print the days
of prison assigned to each losing number
that shorthand as it were which went
virtually unnoticed at the time was of
utmost importance
it was the first appearance of
non-pecuniary elements in the lottery
and it met with great success indeed the
company was forced by its players to
increase the number of unlucky draws
as everyone knows the people of Babylon
are great admirers of logic even of
symmetry it was inconsistent that lucky
numbers should pay off in round silver
coins while unlucky ones were measured
in days and nights of jail certain
moralists argued that possession of
coins did not always bring about
happiness and other forms of Happiness
were perhaps more direct
the lower caste neighborhoods of the
city voiced a different complaint the
members of the Priestly class gambled
heavily and so enjoyed all the
vicissitudes of Terror and hope the poor
with understandable or inevitable Envy
saw themselves denied access
to
that famously delightful even sensual
wheel
the fair and reasonable desire that all
men and women rich and poor be able to
be take part equally in the lottery
inspired indignant demonstrations the
memory of which time has failed to dim
some stubborn Souls could not or
pretended they could not understand that
this was a novice ordo seclorum a
necessary stage of History
a slave stole a crimson ticket the
drawing that determined that the ticket
entitled the bearer to have his tongue
burned out
the code of law provided the same
sentence for stealing a lottery ticket
some Babylonians argued that the slave
deserved the burning iron for being a
thief others more magnanimous that the
Executioner should employ the iron
because thus fate had decreed there were
disturbances there were regrettable
instances of Bloodshed but the masses of
Babylon at last over the opposition of
the well-to-do imposed their will they
saw their generous objectives fully
achieved first
the company
was forced to assume all Public Power
this the unification was necessary
because of the vastness and complexity
of the new operations
second the lottery was made secret free
of charge and open to all
the mercenary sale of lots was abolished
once initiated into the mysteries of
ball every free citizen automatically
took part in the sacred drawings which
were held in the labyrinths of the God
every 60 nights and determined each
Citizen's Destiny until the next drawing
the consequences were incalculable a
lucky draw might win bring about a man's
elevation to the Council of the Magi or
the imprisonment of his enemy secret or
known to all to be so or might allow him
to find in the peaceful dimness of his
room the woman who would begin to
disturb him or whom he had never hoped
to see again an unlucky draw
mutilation this honor of many kinds
death itself
sometimes a single event the murder of C
in a Tavern B's mysterious apotheosis
would be the inspired outcome of 30 or
40 drawings
combining bets was difficult but we must
recall that the individuals of the
company were and still are all powerful
and clever in many cases the knowledge
that certain happy turns or the simple
result of chance would have lessened the
force of those outcomes to forestall
that problem
agents of the company employed
suggestion even Magic
the paths they followed the intrigues
they wove were invariably Secret
to penetrate the innermost hopes and
innermost fears of every man they called
upon astrologers and spies there were
certain Stone Lions a sacred latrine
called kapha some cracks in a Dusty
Aqueduct these places it was generally
believed gave access to the company and
well or ill-wishing persons would
deposit confidential reports on them an
alphabetical file held those dossiers of
in varying veracity
incredibly there was talk of favoritism
of corruption with its customary
discretion the company did not reply
directly instead it scrawled its brief
argument in the rubble of a mask Factory
this apologia is now numbered among the
Sacred Scriptures it pointed out
doctrinally that the lottery is an
interpolation of chance into the order
of the universe and I'd observe that to
accept errors is to strengthen chance
not to contravene it it also noted that
those lions that sacred squatting place
though not disavowed by the company
which preserved the right to consult
them function with no official guarantee
the statement quieted The public's
concerns
but it also produced other effects
perhaps unforeseen by its author it
profoundly altered both the spirit and
the operations of the company I have but
little time remaining we are told the
ship is about to sail but but I will try
to explain
however unlikely it may seem no one
until that time had attempted to produce
a general theory of Gaming
Babylonians are not a speculative people
they obey the dictates of chance
surrender their lives their hopes their
nameless Terror to it but it never
occurs to them to delve into its
Labyrinth and laws or the revolving
spheres that manifest its workings
nonetheless the semi-official statement
that I mentioned
inspired numerous debates of illegal and
mathematical nature from one of them
they're emerged the following conjecture
if the lottery is an intensification of
chance a periodic infusion of chaos into
the cosmos then is it not appropriate
that chance intervene in every aspect of
the drawing not just one is it not
ludicrous the chance should dictate a
person's death while the circumstances
of that death
whether private or public whether drawn
out for an hour or Century should not be
subject to chance
those perfectly reasonable objections
finally prompted sweeping reform the
complexities of the new system
complicated further by it it's having
been in practice for centuries are
understood by only a handful of
Specialists though I will attempt to
summarize them even if only symbolically
let us imagine a first drawing which
condemns an individual to death in
pursuance of that decree another drawing
is held out of that second drawing come
nine possible executors of those nine
four might initiate a third drawing to
determine the name of the Executioner
two might replace the Unlucky draw with
a lucky one the discovery of a treasure
say another might decide that the death
should be exacerbated death with
dishonor that is with or without the
refinement of torture
others might simply refuse to carry out
the sentence
that is the scheme of the lottery put
symbolically in reality the number of
drawings is infinite no decision is
final all Branch into others
the endurance assume that infinite
drawings require infinite time actually
all that is required is that time be
infinitely subdivisible as in the famous
parable of the race with the tortoise
that infinitude coincides remarkably
well with the sinuous numbers of chance
and with the Heavenly archetype of the
lottery beloved by platonists some
distorted echo of our customs seems to
have reached the Tiber in his life of
Antonius Helio gabbales Alias lampardus
tells us that the emperor rode on
seashells the Fate that he intended for
his guests at dinner some would receive
10 pounds of gold others ten house flies
tendor mice 10 bears
it is fair to remember to recall that
Helio gabbales was raised in Asia Minor
among the priests of his eponymous God
there are also impersonal drawings whose
purpose is unclear
one drawing decrees that a sapphire from
Top robana be thrown into the Waters of
the Euphrates another that a bird be
released from the top of a certain Tower
another that every hundred years a grain
of sand be added to or taken from the
countless grains of sand on a certain
Beach
sometimes the consequences are terrible
under the companies beneficent influence
our customs are now steeped in shants
the purchaser of a dozen M4 I have to
masking wine will not be surprised if
one contains a Talisman or a Viper the
Scribe who writes out a contract never
fails to include some error I myself in
this hurried statement have
misrepresented some Splendor some
atrocity perhaps to some mysterious
monotony
are historians the most pers capacious
on the planet have invented a method for
correcting chance it is well known that
the outcomes of this method are in
general trustworthy although of course
they're never divulged without a measure
of deception
besides there's nothing so tainted with
fiction as the history of the company a
paleographic document Unearthed at a
certain Temple may come from yesterday's
drawing or from a drawing that took
place centuries ago no book is published
without some discrepancy between each of
the additions copies
scribes take a secret oath to emit
interpolate alter indirect falsehood is
also practiced
the secret
orders it Con perhaps continually
imparts are no different from those
spread wholesale by imposters besides
who will boast of being a mere imposter
the drunken man who blurts out an absurd
command the sleeping man who suddenly
awakes and turns and chokes to death the
woman sleeping at his side
are they not perhaps implementing one of
the company's secret decisions
that silent functioning like God's
inspires all manner of conjectures
one scariestly suggests that the company
ceased to exist hundreds of years ago
and that the sacred disorder of Our
Lives is purely heredity hereditary
traditional another believes that the
company is eternal and that it shall
endure until the last night when the
last God shall annihilate the Earth
yet another declares that the company is
omnipotent but affects only Small Things
the shades of rust and dust The Cry of a
bird the half dreams that come at dawn
another whispered by Master harisi arcs
says that the company has never existed
and never will
another no less despicable argues that
it makes no difference whether one
affirms or denies the reality of the
shadowy corporation because Babylon is
nothing but an infinite game of chance
so that is the lottery in Babylon by
Jorge Louis Borges found in this
particular uh translation by Andrew
Hurley as the collected fictions one of
my favorite short stories uh not only of
Borges but for me of all time quite
short uh you could say that there are no
real characters in it perhaps the
lottery itself
could be interpreted as a character
undergoing development but it's not
really a character because the lottery
and even the company that administers it
are not protagonists they are rather
instead the interfaces with or between
everybody else in this society and
perhaps even with themselves because
people who are members of the company
are also citizens of Babylon presumably
and so we've got this really interesting
set of conjectures about
a mythical land in which a lottery is
taking place that grows to you know out
of a normal Lottery to become the
archetype of the lottery for the
Babylonians and then determining every
aspect of one's life but not just
passively where one suffers it one also
actively participates in it and it's
possible to have you know some insight
some information about what's going on
but like the narrator himself tells us
everybody is introducing
some measure of inconsistency of
deception of lies or something like that
so we've got to you know fascinating
short story here that I think we can I
know that I when I read it I think about
what would this actually be like and how
would we get information about this and
how would this work is it even possible
or is this something that is purely a
product of the imagination and I've been
reading the and rereading this story now
and thinking about it for well I first
encountered Borges
uh about 30 years ago in the early 90s
as I was reading uh through his
Labyrinth uh volume which includes the
lottery at Babylon is one of its first
short stories and I've been returning to
this one as I have with the previous
story that I I recalled
um the game of rat and dragon by cord
waiter Smith for you know years and
years and years and it never goes stale
it's it's always an interesting
composition to place yourself into by by
reading so that's uh probably enough on
my end about why it is that I like this
story so much after having given it a
reading and I'm curious to see what
other people have to say about the story
or you know any questions that they
might have
um
about you know what what Borges is
actually saying or you know comments and
so we'll give it you know a minute or so
and see if anybody has anything that
they'd they'd like to say in the chat
and I'll respond to that
um in the meantime I'll I'll say that
I'm going to keep doing these readings
every month uh the next one that we have
lined up is uh Graham Green's short
story the hint of an explanation which
is much more we could say theological in
orientation than this which is much more
let's say metaphysical and sociological
um and I've I've got a number of other
short stories I'm always going to pick
ones that I've been particularly
interested in moved by found fascinating
so if you have anything that you'd like
to say I'm happy to uh engage your
thoughts on this wonderful little short
story very short story by Jorge Louis
Borges the lottery at Babylon
foreign
so I'm not seeing anybody with any
comments so this might be a very short
session which is certainly fine by me
um
if you haven't read the uh short story
I'd strongly suggest after hearing it
read aloud that you go and check it out
and if you're not already a you know
reader of Borges and you you like
philosophy
he is definitely a philosopher's writer
you know he doesn't write any novels so
he's not Umberto echo or anybody like
that
um but his short stories are so rich in
philosophical references and play and
implications on so many matters you know
metaphysics epistemology
uh ethical philosophy Aesthetics the
philosophy of language and uh you know
meaning in in larger respects all of
these come together as well as
questions of freedom and determinism
causality all these interesting things
that as philosophers you know we tend to
be captivated by so
I'm not seeing any
other questions or comments I think
we'll wrap this up then around the 25 ah
here we go
um
Nora says have you read Borge's poetry I
have
um I'm not
um
I find myself less interested in his
poetry which is good stuff than in his
prose writing and essay writing kolamus
uh curious if you have any thoughts on
how the company takes on a metaphysical
character well I mean the way the
company takes on a metaphysical
character
is charted out in here in this perhaps
fictitious uh within a fiction within a
fiction uh story that's being told by
the narrator and he's saying my father
has told me that this is the case so you
know there's a couple important steps
along the way right the uh substitution
of a non-pecuniary
element within the game days in in
prison versus money that you would get
the expansion of it I think in order to
become metaphysical it has to
expand to the degree that it permeates
the entire
um
you know culture and society that these
people are in so that any action that a
person takes might in fact be the
company itself as the cause I think
that's I think thinking about it in
terms of causality is where you get the
metaphysics from
uh the ultimate artist has something
that's totally irrelevant here can you
please look into the history of Haiti
it's the most interesting country I've
ever read about that's nice but that's
got nothing to do with Borges
um and uh so I'll just skip over that
here any other questions comments that
people would like uh me to to engage
with before we wrap it up here stuff
that has to do with Borges or with uh
the lottery at Babylon or uh connected
topics that you know causality chance
uh human Freedom all of these
interesting matters that we we look at
hope get another drink of water while
I'm seeing if anybody has anything else
to say
I will remark to that we'll we'll
probably do a few other Borges stories
because he is one of my favorite writers
down the line but will certainly range
over a number of others before we come
back to him but I am thinking this is a
bit of a off topic but it is connected I
am thinking about putting together down
the line a class an online class about
some of Borges
stories
the ones that like the lottery in
Babylon or you know
um you know there's so many other great
ones the memorials would be another
excellent one to do obviously Twan Akbar
orbius territists uh The Garden of
forking paths
um the circular ruins the library of
Babel
um
you know the cult of the Phoenix all of
these and of course the house of
Hysteria and how can we forget that one
um it would be fun to go through these
Story by story and look at what's what's
going on in these what is the philosophy
or philosophies that Borges is
referencing invoking or perhaps even
working out on his own so a lot of uh
good stuff there that'll probably happen
you know not this summer but later on
down the line so all right well I don't
see any further questions or comments so
I think we'll wrap it up here around the
30 minute Mark and I'll say thanks for
everybody for tuning in
um great short story The Lottery in
Babylon by Jorge Louis Borges one that I
will probably be rereading and thinking
about the rest of my life hopefully
you've gotten a little bit captivated by
it and if you haven't started already
reading Borges so definitely somebody
who I recommend spending time with and
lingering over and he's such a wonderful
thinker and writer I think he'll derive
hopefully as much enjoyment out of
reading him as I have so I will see all
of you next month for our next
uh storytelling with Sadler reading
um Graham greens the hint of an
explanation a little bit longer of a
story a little bit more personal uh
another one that I found really clicked
with me and perhaps you'll find that as
well so I'll see you next time
foreign